ça vas y toi oui tu es magnifique
vraiment réagir si matt oxia je regrette
pas d'être venu championne
soit à l'aise ça va te vois ça je peux
voir tes pieds ça dérange pas
[Musique]
c'est très bien que moi j'aime beaucoup
les pieds oui je sais que tu es
fétichistes et non je suis pas parti qui
s'imaginent ont par la suite tu vas
devenir ma famille je sais pas fauquet
les pompiers allez voir les gnocchis
pour voir si ses idées n'étaient pas
voilà tout simplement que tu vas bien
je peux les voir si beau si l'on verra
ça plus tard
humaine en tout cas merci d'être là mais
merci à vous de m'avoir invité vous
étiez donc amoureuse 2010
alors on va on va revenir sur toute
cette affaire où le savez c'est notre
tiff un bien sûr tous les mardis sachez
humaine en tout cas que vous n'avez
peut-être pas tout perdu puisque il ya
une personne autour de la table voilà
qui apparemment vous êtes bien je vous
dirais qu'il s'agit dans un instant
sachez que c'est plus de ce côté là
voilà un gars c'est pas moi d'arriver
nom
n'est pas mathieu de gens savent où ça
vous d'histoire
alors heureusement c'est pas maintenant
je voulais mettre à côté de nuit bah
ouais bah ça n'est pas benjamin castaldi
non plus d'autant que manu merci ça
n'est pas quitte berder six pages et là
il se dit ouf
c'est pas là
y aura-t-il
qu'entre géraldine et guillaume natton
géraldine et y met vous êtes éducatrice
sportive à marseille vous avez vous avez
divorce à 19 ans il est parachuté dans
l'armée et vous avez fait voilà vous
étiez exactement et humaine 1 vous
discutiez avec melvin c'est ça est
depuis longtemps depuis cinq mois on
savait au départ ce débat s'il y'avait
il y avait un petit truc vous allez nous
raconter tout ça il y avait quand même
un petit clienti délirantes il s'agit
ensuite tout se passait très bien la
base avec melvin un bas par texto c'est
plus simple les gens vont aimer tous à
vous les aimiez bien oui je l'aimé bien
hier d'henri si on se rencontre et ils
se sont rencontrés cinq mois à se parler
sur les réseaux et c'est vrai que iman a
repoussé de nombreux soit la rencontre
réelle parce que elle a été déçue déçue
d'un soir ou melvin a oublié de
raccrocher son téléphone est en fait
elle a entendu ce qu'elle n'aurait pas
dû entendre
vous allez découvrir cette affaire
melvin
vous êtes fait honteusement bouffer le
cul
donc j'ai entendu une discussion
utilisé à ton ami ton ami tu disais
alors la fille que je vois pas
ça dit oui c'est frank thomas ce même si
j'ai fantômas y en a d'autres j'en ai
beaucoup d'autres
c'était fantôme est ce parce qu'on se
voyait pas et qu'en gros tu discutes
avec une autre femme
je voulais pas que tu saches que j'aime
beaucoup plaire aux femmes j'aime
beaucoup séduire et lorsque game j'ai
mon jeu j'aime provoquer sa série de
choix mais c'est des y'a rien du tout
c'est des amis je serai mais c'est ce
que ce très bon sait-on que s'ils
tombent
alors discuté avoir trompé non s'est pas
trompé alors si on commence à discuter
eu trop un peu dur iman ah bon oui bon
il faut être sincère dès le début quoi
toi même si c'est parce qu'il a parlé
que d'autres filles déjà ça te branche
consumer parle avec d'autres mecs
j'avais été sincère avec lui parce qu'il
m'a posé la même question et que moi
c'était ma voiture n'était pas ensemble
tu vois du coup bah oui j'ai bien
compris mais c'est mon par l'ensemble du
coup parler avec toi mais après j'ai
raconté j'ai mes amis tu vois j'ai une
copine oui je comprends drapeau comme
l'a formulé dans l'émission est un prêt
couple basséen playcool m'apprenait ne
s'est jamais vu je tiens à prix coûtant
et
donc quoi bon après coup que le peuple
pour moins un cadre au stade jacques en
gohelle et m'ont parlé bien ensemble
massage et jacky pellet six nouveaux les
filles ouais j'aimais bien son caractère
ne touchez pas je l'aimé bien quoi et
et après je pars pour lesparre la vie
des filles à côté mais c'est pas moi de
charroux mais c'est pas et pas en boccia
route chat non non non non mais c'est
parce qu'il paierait 48 un char ou
jamais c'est déjà beau
la douche à un char oh oui c'est à
charbon actif les clichés dans toutes
les mains rien pour voilà qui est bon
pour eux
voilà projetés pas encore incertain
rouffach attendait jean loric guillaume
ça
c'est mon chariot
[Rires]
donc ça ça m'a est à quel âge de 82 25
là ça va
or jeune j'ai compris bien sûr tu as
raison on compte en profiter mais bien
sûr il a oublié de dire aussi qu'il
m'avait menti aussi pendant l'émission
il dit qu'il avait 27 ans monsieur non
mais ça va
tout le temps occupé cette scène aussi
un nom mais ça c'est un truc à lui c'est
david anticipées daniel aussi parce
entendons deux ans la tjv 24 manu dans
les derniers sont là c'est normal qu'ils
stricte à leur hymen s'avère un petit
peu déçu parce qu'il est contrarié c'est
pas que je vois là c'est pas que je suis
que je sois déçu je suis un peu
contrarié gg j'ai du mal - fait choper
une féministe j'aime pas qu'on prenne
les femmes pour des cons en fait on est
pas on n'est pas là des prisons tu as
appris jeudi pour le compte pas du tout
parce que justement parce que en droit
de conserver témoins les j ai dû lui
c'est vrai ce par la violence ou naji
quand je te les 10 en fait moi je te le
dire alors mais je demande en chine donc
évidente revenir sur l'audi a été
attrapé la maladie que tu m'avais dit
en
couple encore très couple s'était creusé
entre les couples qu'est ce qui te
dérange donc là toi toi tu voulais rien
faire avec lui à cause de ça parce qu'on
va voir vous avez décidé de rester amis
voilà regarder et d'ailleurs vous allez
vous dire ce qu'il en est aujourd'hui
parce que je me sens tout les 2000 à
l'air bien il mène justement a déçu par
cette aventure et j'aime pas ça moi les
ont déçus je te dise ça ça m'interpelle
j'ai envie d aider voilà comment comment
voler les débats grâce à y ait
aujourd'hui
je te le dis clairement je veux je
préfère regarder en ami je pense que ça
sert à rien en plus
je pense qu'on est plus sur l'as cannes
zone non
pour moi je sais que j'ai raison je sais
que je parle pour toi tu as raison d'un
mois j'ai raison je n'ai pas encore
compris coupe tous les lots prix
j'ai l'impression qu'on est en train de
braquer ouassara demandera que je suis
déçu le ton comportement comme quand tu
veux comme tu réagis jamais
venir c'est vraiment
devant
au revoir ma vie donc sourire
mon dieu
m
alors donc voilà donc toi ce qui m'a
énervé donc c'est qu'ils parlent avec
d'autres filles tu l'as pas tu l'as pas
accepter ça et pourquoi
mais pas ça va il faut parler
amicalement avec youtube quoi j'en avais
parlé est ce que tu pars avec d'autres
femmes surtout
ça
fait un peu trop mis des sites avait été
avec et me voilà avec un peu de retard
et c'est ça c'est ça tu es parce que tu
es passé l'ancien militaire c'est des
coquetteries te dis g27 il a 24 il parle
avec d'autres filles papa
ça va jamais vu après sa demande en
mariage non mais c'est vrai mais bien
mais là
j'ai 27 ans et millions s'est dit aux
laiteries après un débat avec des cas
1600 mais il mène sans charlie pour
jamais s'il avait parlé alors que vous
étiez déjà un couple alors penser
effectivement que il ya une sorte un
sentiment de trahison mais là
visiblement si vous étiez en train de
vous et de vous tourner autour et donc
peut enfin y avait rien de coûts ont
commencé à se tourner autour et à
construire une base de confiance même si
on s'était jamais vu vous avez dit je te
rappelle quand même en dessous avec ce
jour mr des papas oui ce que c'était la
vraie raison parce que quand on voit
quelqu'un pour la première fois est ce
qu'il n'y avait pas le feeling c'est ça
ce que ça cache quelque chose
mais il avait raison l'élément dit la
vérité et puis en arrivant il m'a passé
rassuré quand je vais parler mais dont
qui en examen au début a eu le plaisir
la shelby le canada mais il te plait il
te plaît s'il vous plaît moyer
physiquement c'est un beau garçon a
autorisé le beau gosse s'est d'ailleurs
témoin sur sable un peu je pense que
c'était à moi de retourner le compliment
mais je suis confiant sur le coup t'es
mignon tu
malvin c'est vrai que chaque semaine ya
beaucoup de gens qui vous ont accusé
d'être un couple fake et qui ont mis en
avant le fait que vous habitez pas loin
du tout l'un d'eux je crois quelques
kilomètres comment ça c'est que vous
soyez jamais lu avant et bien la
problématique et venait de ma part parce
que melvin limite ils étaient prêts à
mener devant chez moi juste moi qu'il y
avait du mal à l'affronter à faire
affronter voileux
vraiment bout mais je stresse ya l'idée
de le voir gina clair mais à présent je
les dis c'est sincère il ya des gens qui
disent aussi qu'en fait quand vous êtes
arrivé vous saviez déjà que vous alliez
le jeter parce que sur les réseaux vous
aviez détecter vous aviez même contacté
d'autres gens vous saviez qui parlait à
plein de filles absolument pas moi j
attends mais juste qui se dit c'est
qu'on dit que en fait au moment où vous
arrivez déjà c'est pour le jeter non ça
s'est pas passé comme ça moi quand je
suis arrivé j'ai préféré prévenir la
prod celle dont il ya une discussion qui
que j'ai entendu malheureusement il n'a
pas raccroché son portable donc vous
avez entendu quoi parce qu'on retire
parce que qu'est ce qu'il a dit dans ces
discussions dans cette discussion ne
vous aidera à cocher son portable son
ami lui poser la question alors ça en
est où avec ta copine un email il m'a
dit oui non son collègue est différente
au mas pardonner parce que wade nous a
jamais répondu non mais ça comme je le
connais pas je couds selon l'oeuvre de
moi je connaissais pas fantômas way
jarry corps bougeait pas il a une forme
que je n'existais pas mais que j'étais
là c'est mignon répond ne t'inquiète pas
je l'aï ya pas que l 1 je suis pas juste
un gamin je vais pas parler juste avec
qui mène alors qu'elle a plein d'autres
qui me court après mais voilà on y voit
là il était un petit peu son ego de mecs
mais voilà vous avez
c'est normal c'est bien connu c'était
son ego de mecs voilà alors iman toi ton
est aujourd'hui est-ce que tu as trouvé
l'amour malheureusement non mais depuis
rien il ya beaucoup de messages ouais du
coup je suis relecture doucement
doucement joker d'accord donc tu crois
peut déposer des cv voilà
[Rires]
m
[Applaudissements]
il faut que tu mettes un chèque baril
qui tentent
de motivation et humer les trois
dernières déclarations d'impôts ça ne
vient pas et on va voir ce qu'on peut
faire
il mène qu'est ce que tu cherches pas
aussi un homme
un vrai bonhomme à un petit garçon à il
est peut-être un peu trop jeune alors
guillaume genton yao genton je suis jack
daniels
et aime pas le mensonge en tombe bien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
d'ailleurs là tu peux y aller
non mais c'est dommage alors toi toi tu
es en couple il paraît qu à saint marc
vachon en cause dans une fille de
l'afrique aux amériques alba et même là
c'est vrai
avec elle que tu discuté pendant qu'on
se parle et au sort dépend pas du tout
pas du tout parce qu'en fait non pas du
tout correctement par l'ensemble je t'ai
pas je prépare avec elle c'est très
récent paru sur sa durée t'es sérieux
très sérieux quoi t'es vraiment
interview je suis un point mais sûrement
moins creusé que donne m donc en bas
c'est une femme bajeux chats font ça
s'hérite pas mis beaucoup de temps
je suis un petit enfant d'un vrai homme
pour moi chez nous c'était mais ce que
je veux me suis maintenant 25 ans je
sais que je me posais je fasse des
avancées avec moi et ma femme je sais
pas comment tu as voulu marier anissa à
nice à elle une cousine
ça va aller il faut signer les deux
mamans c'est les célibataires d'accord
ainsi le marbre premier regard elle est
célibataire à quoi cécile demeurent au
premier regard
nice est content
casilla
je crois pas c'est si les célibataires
les plus
manifestes et maniema
s'appelle anissa mais moi je m'appelle
wyden voilà donc non mais elle elle est
là elle est là elle est dans les parages
va être emballé la voilà voilà voilà ces
messieurs
[Applaudissements]
alors à nice à taëf et mario premier
regard
on m'a cherché on va chercher sur google
et donc toi maintenant tu es avec avec
medicine depuis combien de temps ça fait
deux mois maintenant alors commence à 60
rue mais ça se passe très bien c'est pas
du tout un chat roux c'est pas un petit
garçon franchement
pas dans la vie de tous les jours mais
ma compagne bête de partout et h 24 ans
en tant que les chauffeurs rumeurs
n'ont pas pris un par amour on fait
froid mais sa
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
rencontre et même en voyant les scènes
sont assez agréables
envoyé de message est en fait le premier
j'avais vu et 2 ng répondu parce qu'il
m'a fait
[Rires]
alors et donc ils mènent malheureusement
la crau vais pas sérieux c'est pour ça
qu'elle a choisi de ne pas faire
d'histoires à quoi tu trouve très
sérieux avec avec moi et on va dire hey
man ce soir bah je te je voulais te dire
que ben je pense que tu peux trouver
quelqu'un bay qui ne soit pas et
charroux qui ne soit pas un petit garçon
en ce cas moi avec mes jean ba ça se
passerait bien c'est moins bon
c'est tout vert du mois mais bah si mais
avec mon avis ça va marcher
meilleur
c'est bon t'es content
ça va durer cette affaire
allez vous vous faire un petit bisou
serra madoff
[Applaudissements]
d'études partira juste quand je vais
lancer de suivre une balade dans les
parages
à
côté
sa cote est de melvin ça va lui même ça
fait plaisir de les voir heureux comme
ça je dois bien sûr quoi c'est vrai
bien sûr je ne suis pas comme une loi
normale
merci